[Applause]
thank you so much for being here people
oh yeah nice they're nice they're nice
they're nice people here you're
wondering got a wonderful state here and
uh first of all I want to say I want to
say I'm a huge fan of your name your
name you of the best names like rock
Obama when I first heard it I thought I
was sure it was Irish when I first
there's an apostrophe for the oh I knew
that
and Barack is actually an ancient Celtic
name very nice so we're ancient cousin
I'm taking you to Ireland someday oh
this is my brother here now it's a lot I
have to ask you first of all you live in
Chicago your wife is from here any
advice for me I'm alone I'm a guy I
don't know the area what would you tell
a guy well you know where should I go
today the key is to get into the
neighborhoods you know Millennium Park
is beautiful and and Wrigley Field
everybody knows about but but you know
going going out going out into the
neighborhoods visiting some of the local
restaurants for example my my favorite
restaurant Chicago is a place on the
west side called MacArthur's some folks
know MacArthur's in some of the best
soul food in Chicago food and I mean
you'll stand out a little bit I will not
there are many six six guys in the
restaurant it's about time they saw a
giant red pompadour in there
I love my soul food bring it on now is
it true that you've gone to the same
barber shop is it true here in Chicago
for 20 years I'm going to paint by Hyde
Park hair salon Hyde Park House of
burgers okay
you tell people I'm going to the barber
shop or it's time for my trip to the
hair salon oh no the it's it's called
hair salon but when you go in there it's
it's more shop than salon right and it
sounds like a nice kind of down-to-earth
place the you sit down I the first time
I went there was with a guy named Wally
he is an old grumpy guy they say sit
down what do you want and I'd say well
I'm not sure okay just shut up and he'd
start cutting up that's a great service
guys but but now I've got a guy who's he
and I we've been together for about 10
years
[Applause]
we'll say the relationship between a man
and his barber then that is a sacred
it's a real bond business where do you
get your hair cut combing I don't this
isn't real
this is scientists work on this this is
this is a high density polymer that NASA
invented hair hair is for wimps
this has robotics in it it can do things
I'm an ass by the way I want to talk
about something first time that you had
a real intense national exposure and the
first time I think you came to a lot of
people's attention 2004 Democratic
National Convention you gave the keynote
address
you blew everybody away people are still
talking about that do you ever use you
have such a rhetorical power have you
ever had you ever go home to your family
and try and use that oratorical power
the I'll tell you a quick story I you
know we have dinner together
my wife asked my two daughters seven and
four Malia
how was your day she'll say tell us
about it four-year-old Sasha how was
your day they asked my wife how's your
day then finally my wife says well let's
ask daddy how his day was and my
four-year-old will say boring and my
wife will say well that's not nice you
know actually people come and listen to
Daddy speak and and the two of them fall
out of their chairs they think that's
the funniest thing that's a question
that somebody would be interested yeah
their father has to say kids just don't
care yeah different time to just jump up
behind a podium in front of your kids to
tell them you know go to your room
great using the great Barack Obama voice
my fellow Obama's
you will clean your room in this century
yes
have you always been a gifted speaker if
you always was it something that you
developed over time oh you know I have
flopped so many times I think it's like
being a comic you know you get up and
everything and sometimes it's working
for you but you know that time where
everybody's talking about you you start
getting kind of hot flashes and you know
no I I know exactly what you're talking
about anyone who's you and so how do you
handle when you because people I think
just assume that you're you're you're
such a gifted speaker that you've never
had those moments describe what it's
like for you when you're up there and
you feel like it's not working you're
not getting work and and and the main
mistake everybody makes in it and I do
the same thing is you just keep on
talking right because you think well
eventually I'm gonna come up with
something that they like and that makes
it worse because what happens is not
only are you bad but you're long-winded
right right and and so you just throw
out random words at a certain point corn
dog onion blueberry anything here people
yeah yeah but I think that's what's been
happening in the White House lately
this dry throat so anything gets the
refrigerator see if it sticks yeah well
well let me ask you something I know
President Bush is famous for nicknames
has he has he tried to give you a
nickname he tried he loves to give
everybody the thing I can't tell whether
he's trying to give me a nickname or
whether he just can't pronounce my name
sometimes who calls me mama mama mama
mama sometimes he calls me rock because
he comes you hood rock rock that rock is
cool rock is my man rocks I like that
yeah yeah keep on keep on the get rock
mr. president you are right they're
gonna think he's having a fit or
something now I'm curious you you have
been very successful you've had a lot of
obviously a lot of success and a lot of
adulation you've been very successful I
think it remaining humble and having a
sense of humor about yourself is it is
it is that come naturally to you is it
your it's your wife yeah it's nice when
someone else does it for you yeah she
tells me about my ears she talks about
my ears a lot that's an old standard how
big they are
oh really that's nice so your kids are
saying boring and she's like yeah
basically often I come home feeling
pretty full of myself and he they
knocked me down pretty quick yeah I
think that's what our loved ones are for
that's why I feel good oh yeah
thanks mom now I have to ask you I
wouldn't be doing my job that's not true
I'm a comedian not a pundit but but I'm
gonna ask anyway so many people are
speculating you hear Barack Obama is
going to be a presidential candidate no
wait or he's gonna do I just want to say
if there's something you'd like to say
here there's probably never a better
venue than right now this is the kind of
thing you want to say just after
Chewbacca has made out with George when
I was thinking about you as my running
mate
it sounds good Obama over and over obama
o'brien sounds amazing yeah Obama
O'Brien it would be the worst thing you
ever did
after you you think it was funny and
then like a day later he'd be like this
guy is an idiot come on over let's talk
this was um it's been a thrilling week
for us but it was a real honor to have
you be on our last show here in Chicago
and I know you're a busy person but we
were thrilled when you said you'd
stopped bonds and I I love Conan O'Brien
and most of all I love the audience here
[Applause]